sad news today i'm afraid from the new  york post it says the dc comics film  batgirl will be completely shelved by  warner brothers a top hollywood source  told the post what's happening here is  that they made this film batgirl and  they spent 100 million dollars on it and  now they're just it's so bad that  they're simply not going to release it  at all nobody will ever see it that's  how bad it is which i find quite  hilarious also of course  it's a bad movie it's batgirl  no big surprise that your investment was  wasted  and like i've said before with these  female superheroes  it doesn't even  begin to work when you have a female  superhero if the character doesn't have  actual superpowers  i'm the batman i'm supposed to take it  seriously that this  that this girl  with no superpowers is going around  beating up bad guys in her leather bat  outfit  so 100 million dollars wasted  pretty great stuff